you know Michael you mentioned
Millennials and another topic came
across my mind today where Millennials
are now taking adulting classes it's
becoming a new trend they learn basic
skills like sewing cooking how to deal
with relationships we know they're there
cuz they're living at home longer what
is it with this delayed adolescence and
what is it doing to our society well I
would worry about speaking ill of my
fellow Millennials but statistically
none of them are awake this early to be
watching this program so it's okay
adulting is the phrase that Millennials
use to congratulate themselves for not
behaving like children and I'm actually
all for the adulting classes this is
very important according to the US
Census more than 1/3 of young Americans
18 to 34 are living in their childhood
homes with their parents this number is
way up since 2005 we now know that the
majority of American Millennials have
relied on their parents for financial
assistance since turning 21 more know
Millennials are living with their
parents that are living with spouses or
are living with roommates and this is
because their teachers and their parents
have failed them they may have failed
Millennials you're exactly right listen
I don't even blame the Millennials I
blame the Boomers I've lame I blame the
parents who did they didn't they
confused the fact that parenting is
about child rearing it's about raising
up citizens and kids and teaching them
instead of putting them in front of an
iPad and saying good luck this is
exactly right you now have an entire
generation maybe the parents maybe the
teachers meant well but the road to hell
is paved with good intentions so you
have this completely ignorant completely
helpless generation that not only can't
balance a checkbook they don't even know
that they should go out and get a
full-time job they can't cook they can't
so they can't do much of anything at all
this doesn't help Society this doesn't
help the Millennials themselves so if
they've got to learn how to adult at the
age of 35 that's a little pathetic but
better late than never
glasses mic
okay